clouds versus dirt yet the case dirt  being an actual practitioner even though  I have a 600 person company with filled  with twenty year olds through every  direction as a 40 year old in that  company nobody actually knows how to do  social media better than me I'm a  practitioner I know every nook and  cranny about snapchat Pinterest  Instagram right now and so when you do  something you have to know your craft  clouds you have to know why you're doing  it at the highest level when I was  getting D's and F's in high school in  the 90s when the narrative was going to  college is the only way to be successful  in America I was told by teachers that I  was a loser even though I was making  $2,000 a weekend selling baseball cards  as a 15 year old  I think 99.9% people watching this right  now live in the middle and I think it's  the most dangerous place to be